The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: The first
problem set is out,
and I should let you know
that Hayden is watching out
for you, because we
actually trimmed off one
problem from past problem sets.
So this is a little bit
of a revamp from the past,
and slightly shorter.
So the trade-off is maybe
asking slightly fewer questions,
but then emphasizing
a little bit
more the discussive responses
from you on the problem set.
As we talked about
last time, we'd
really like a little bit
of textual description
from you about the problem
and your thought processes
on those.
OK, good-- so let's
start with today.
If you recall, Tuesday
was the broad overview,
a little bit of
the outline of what
we're going to be seeing
throughout the course
of the semester.
Today I'm going to focus in
a little bit on semiconductor
process technology, but with
a real emphasis on variation
in semiconductor processes.
And the basic agenda here
is give you a very quick--
I think it's a four-slide
process summary
of a typical process sequence.
It's going to be a bit stylized.
Another reading
assignment that is coming,
but I have not quite
issued yet in order
to give you some room to work on
problem set 1, will be chapter
2 of May and Spanos, which is a
fairly nice condensed, but good
enough depth and detail
description of semiconductor
process technology.
So it is an excellent
50-page, 30 to--
well, I guess chapter 2 is
about something like 50 pages--
nice introduction
to and some details
on semiconductor processing.
But what I want to do is set
a little bit of a baseline
to make sure everybody has
a course picture of what
is involved in making
integrated circuits,
since that is going to
be one of the processes
that we use to illustrate
lots of things.
And so what I'm going to talk a
little bit about after going--
flying through the
whole process sequence
is some of the
types of variation
that arise in
microfabrication, with emphasis
on parametric variation.
And then we'll talk a little
bit about temporal variation--
run to run, wafer to
wafer, if you will--
and then spatial variations.
And semiconductor processing
is an interesting one,
because there are
nesting of replication
of the products within
additional geometric
structures.
So we'll talk about
that a little bit.
And then what we'll be doing
mixed in with the discussion
of these types of
variation is trying
to give you a little bit of a
preview, some examples drawn
from both the literature
and some of the research
that my group has been doing
over the last 10 years or so.
We'll try to give
you a preview of some
of the kinds of manufacturing
control techniques
that we'll be diving
in much more detail
throughout the term.
So we'll see a
little bit early on
about basic statistical
analysis, trying to decide,
is there something
varying here or not--
basic detection and
analysis of that.
Then we'll talk a little
bit about process modeling,
especially from an
empirical point of view,
and a little bit of the boundary
between physical modeling
and empirical modeling.
I'll give you a little
example of that.
And then we'll talk about
using those kinds of models
for process optimization and
some of the kinds of strategies
that arise to have
robust designs--
and then lastly, a very
simple example of feedback
control in a unit process in
semiconductor fabrication.
So the following is from a book.
It's a little bit dated.
About 10 years old.
It's actually an
interesting book,
because it's about
statistical case
studies in industrial
process improvement, where
almost all of the
cases are really
drawn from the
semiconductor industry.
So before they dive into
those statistical methods,
they themselves give
a very quick overview
of the semiconductor
fabrication process.
So I like this example or this--
I think there's three or four
slides that have a sequence--
a little bit because it's fairly
simplified and abstracted,
so we can go through it quickly.
But the real reason I love this
is there are mistakes in it.
There are errors, things
that don't necessarily make
physical sense or don't quite--
well, a lot of
this is, of course,
simplification of the process
to get it down to something
easy, but even in that--
with that caveat,
there's things that
are just-- don't quite line up.
So your challenge is to
try to point out to me,
as we go through it,
what can't be right--
even if you don't have a lot
of semiconductor background.
So let's see if you
can catch these.
Actually, let's see if I
can skip ahead briefly.
I'm skipping to the
end of the sequence.
This is step 25.
What we're showing here is
the fabrication sequence
of building up thin films
on the surface of the wafer,
as well as changing the
material properties of parts
of the surface of the
wafer, scoped in or zoomed
in to trying to build
a single transistor.
Now, there are people that build
and sell single transistors,
but really we're talking
integrated circuits.
At the ICC Conference
earlier this week,
Intel announced their 2 billion
transistor microprocessor.
So that's the level
of integration
that's out there now.
We're going to focus on one.
Clearly, when we talk
a little bit later,
part of the challenge is to
build a product with 2 billion
of these things and
have them all work.
So this is a wonderful
industry in terms
of exquisite manufacturing
control required
to have all 2 billion
things work on your circuit.
But to get a picture of
what's really going on,
we're going to focus in
on a single transistor.
And there's a picture
of it geometrically,
and over on the right here
is a very abstracted picture
of the function of a
single MOSFET transistor.
And the basic idea
is that this can
act as an electronic switch
under the application
of different voltage
conditions so that one
can control the flow of current
in an on/off kind of fashion,
and therefore perform
certain logic functions,
depending on the presence
or absence of voltage
on components of the structure.
The real action
is, right down here
in the center of the device, in
the center of the transistor,
you essentially have
a source and a drain.
These are electrically
conductive,
and these little blue
things are, in this picture,
aluminum paths or metal paths--
metal connections, if you will--
that make contact to
the semiconductor--
the silicon semiconductor
layer underneath.
These red regions have
been very highly doped--
and we'll see the
process for doing
that-- that make them also
much more metallic in nature.
They are highly conductive.
So this is how we
get electrical access
down to the semiconductor.
The interesting
part is the silicon
that has been only
lightly doped--
and that's what I think
these little dots are meant
to indicate-- to control the
degree at which it will conduct
under different amounts
of potential applied
to it from the
control of a gate.
This blue-- I guess it's
green on this picture--
this is the gate electrode.
And eventually, it's typically
made out of polysilicon,
and eventually
contacted also by metal
so that we can apply positive
or negative voltage to the gate.
And if we apply in a
typical NMOS transistor
enough of a positive
voltage, what
we do is we attract lots
and lots of negative charges
to counteract the
positive charges
we're creating on the
surface of the gate.
We create lots of--
or attract or
generate an inversion
with lots and lots of
electrons, negative charge
down here in this
very, very thin surface
layer of the silicon.
So the semiconducting
silicon can
be made to conduct under certain
voltage or bias conditions,
and now current can
flow from the gate--
or underneath the gate from
the source to the drain.
So if we apply a positive
voltage, we turn the thing on,
and current can flow.
Alternatively, if we apply
either an opposite voltage,
or no voltage in a typical
MOSFET for logic operations,
the conductivity of
the silicon layer
will be so low that current is
blocked, and the thing is off.
So the basic idea here is
we need to control carefully
the conditions and properties
of the silicon layer,
and then we need to set up
the rest of the geometry
to be able to have
access to the--
and form the structures for
the source drain and the gate.
So what we're going to
see in this sequence
is how we start from
some raw material,
build up the thin film
layers, and differentiate
both the geometry and
change those properties.
So in this picture,
we're starting out here
with the silicon in white.
We add or create a thin
layer of silicon dioxide
in this picture.
Now, there's lots of
different processes--
many of these are discussed in
more detail in May and Spanos--
for creating silicon dioxide.
One is deposit on the surface.
The other is to actually, quote,
"grow" a silicon dioxide layer.
And that is, we essentially
subject the wafer
to an oxygen carrying ambient,
either O2 or a H2O vapor
kind of ambient.
And the oxygen will react with
the silicon, forming SiO2,
and we have a very nice
stable silicon dioxide layer.
It turns out that
that simple process
of being able to grow a very
high-quality silicon dioxide
layer was kind of
the crux process
that enabled integrated
circuits in some fashion.
And we'll talk about it a
little bit later, but basically,
we're going to need
insulating layers
between conducting layers--
one conducting layer
being the silicon itself.
The others-- when we build
multiple levels of wiring,
we need insulators between them.
But in particular, for the
formation of that transistor,
the creation of a very
good high-quality,
very stable,
well-controlled oxide
insulating layer between the
gate electrode and the silicon
electrode was crucial.
That forms, basically, a metal
gate oxide semiconductor,
or MOS transistor structure.
The ability to create
a MOS capacitor
and then contact it
on the sides, where
you can invert the silicon
layer was a big challenge.
The first transistors were,
in fact, bipolar transistors.
Shortly after the invention
of the bipolar transistor,
Shockley went off on his
own, and also invented
the MOS transistor.
In the very early versions,
a different semiconductor
material was used--
different element than silicon.
Anybody know?
What were the first
transistors built out of?
AUDIENCE: Germanium--
DUANE BONING:
Germanium-- why aren't
all of our transistors
built out of germanium now?
We'll come back to that.
Some of them are
starting to be again.
The problem is, if
you oxidize germanium,
you get an insulating layer.
The problem is it's
extremely soft and unstable.
And in fact, if you oxidize
the surface of germanium,
you can wipe away the oxide.
It is not stable
and manufacturable.
And so it was
really this ability
right here to be able to grow a
very hard, high-quality silicon
dioxide that was crucial
for being able to build up
for both the conversion
over to silicon
and for being able to build
up complex structures.
OK, so we've got this thin
silicon dioxide layer here
that has been grown.
Now what we want to
do is start building
the region where
we're actually going
to have the active device.
So we're going to go
through a sequence
here that gets repeated
again and again this
is referred to as the
photolithographic sequence.
And so what we start
with is depositing
a thin layer of photoresist,
shown in red here,
this is typically spun on.
So this is a polymer
type of material.
It's in a solvent so that
one can drop the material on,
and then spin the wafer
very rapidly in order
to get the controlled
film thickness that one
wants for the photoresist.
And this is--
interacts with light
in one two different ways.
You can have positive
or negative photoresist.
What's shown in the next
picture is a typical--
let's see.
Is this is one
positive or negative?
This one's a
positive photoresist,
because we're going to basically
transform or imprint, if you
will, the mask layer
here in the same fashion
with the underlying photoresist.
The basic idea of
the photoresist
is it contains
photoactive compounds
that underexposure to light
will change the polymer
linking of the photoresist.
Yeah-- question?
AUDIENCE: But I understand
the [INAUDIBLE] sorry.
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I understand
the [INAUDIBLE]
as the [INAUDIBLE]
the black part.
DUANE BONING: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
black part.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: That's
exactly right.
AUDIENCE: --change the
chemical structure.
DUANE BONING: That's right.
The goal is to take some
design, from some CAD system
or whatever, that enables us
to differentiate the surface.
The design is used
to make a physical--
well, in most cases, a physical
glass plate, if you will,
that has metal blocking areas--
the chromium-- that
are intended to block
the transmission of the
light source in some regions,
and allow it in others.
So that's exactly right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
are not exposed.
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
So this is actually a cutaway.
This is going on for--
if this is only a
couple of microns
wide, the entire wafer--
or the entire chip, depending
on how the photolithography--
it goes on forever.
So this is just a cutaway.
AUDIENCE: No, but I mean
the middle is exposed.
DUANE BONING: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, so we can
wash away the exposed part?
DUANE BONING: Right--
AUDIENCE: But it's
not solidifying the--
DUANE BONING: No.
OK, so that's the two types
of photoresist activity.
So in this case, with the
positive photoresist, what
happens is the light energy
from the exposure system
will break down some
of the polymer chains
in the-- in these
photoactive polymer chains
in the photoresist,
weakening them.
We then go in and do a develop
process, where a chemical
solvent is used that attacks
the weakened polymer chains
and rinses it away.
So we have the
spin on resist, we
do the exposure to light through
the mask, then we do a develop,
rinsing away the resist.
And in the positive case,
the pattern on the mask
is transferred
directly, if you will,
into the pattern
of the photoresist.
There is also, in fact
more commonly used,
a negative photoresist
that actually
works in the opposite
way, which is anywhere
where the light
exposes, it actually
strengthens the chemical bonding
of the photoactive compound
in the polymer, and makes it
more resistant to dissolution
in the developer--
in which case,
I would rinse away
everything that
did not get exposed and
leave the pattern which
did get exposed.
So actually, there's some
degree of design choice
in picking a positive and
negative photoresist, depending
on some manufacturing
control issues.
It turns out, if you're
developing away material,
you might, in one
case or the other,
be able to actually
overdevelop or overexpose
slightly and control
slightly the line
width of these features
a little bit better
in one photoresist
case than the other,
depending on what
you want to do.
OK, so so far, this
sequence of three steps
has simply transferred
the mask pattern
into a photoresist pattern,
but the photoresist
itself only temporary.
Its purpose is to act as a mask
to allow us to differentiate
more aggressive
physical transformations
of the remaining wafer.
And in particular, in
the following case,
as shown here in step
5, this is saying
what we want to do now is do
another etch of the silicon
dioxide layer, in
this case using
a plasma-- a gas plasma etch.
I guess that's what the little
lightning storm here is.
So this is typically done in
a very low pressure vacuum
equipment, where we
have some feed gas.
We apply RF energy to dissociate
the species in the gas.
Many of those species then
become very highly chemically
reactive, and they interact
with the surface of the wafer
and etch away
particular species.
So one would design
the plasma process
to preferentially etch away
the silicon dioxide, while not
attacking, or only
very, very slowly
attacking the protective
photoresist layer.
So what this is
allowing us to do
is essentially
vertically etch down
into the silicon dioxide layer.
Now, in this picture, what
they're trying to do here
is show that we are partially
etching some silicon dioxide
layer away, apparently leaving
a small remaining level or layer
of silicon dioxide.
So you can see that
shadow down in there?
What they're trying
to show in this case
is they're leaving this
thin silicon dioxide
layer that is going to be that
insulator between the gate
electrode and the silicon
that we talked about
in the final structure.
So typically, this
might be, oh--
what you might have is
close to modern technology.
You might have a 1/2
a micron in the--
of silicon dioxide
that you want--
fairly thick silicon dioxide--
out here to act as a very, very
big insulating layer separating
your metal electrodes
from other components.
But this silicon
dioxide layer that's
used between the gate
and the semiconductor
needs to be extremely thin.
And the reason is
the closer I can
get my two plates of that
capacitor, the more control--
well, the more
capacitance I have,
but the more control I have
all of the silicon surface.
So the harder I can turn the
device on, the more current
I can flow per unit
area, and so on.
So in this process,
apparently we're
etching from about 1/2 micron--
5,000 angstroms-- down to--
we might be at 100 angstrom.
Or below remaining gate oxide
layer is, in a modern process,
really what you want.
Everybody happy with that?
AUDIENCE: So what
is the tolerance?
DUANE BONING: Hooray--
how would you do that?
Yeah.
What is the tolerance?
Well, first off, to
answer your question,
you want that to be 100
angstroms, plus or minus--
well, in fact, some of the
kinds of control that they quote
are plus or minus
5 angstroms, which
is less than an atomic
layer in some cases.
What they actually
mean is, on average,
over certain kinds of areas.
But how would you
actually achieve
that with the
manufacturing process?
How are you going to etch
down through 5,000 angstroms
and stop 1,000 angstroms,
or 100 angstroms
before you hit the silicon?
Very carefully-- no, the
answer is you're not.
You're not.
There are some
additional reasons
why one wouldn't want to
do it, but at present, we
don't have the
observability to be
able to know when we're
within 100 angstroms.
Second, there's no way
you can be that uniform
across the whole wafer.
What if, on one
part of the wafer,
instead of 5,000 angstroms,
it was 5,001 angstroms?
By the time I get down to
know etching 4,900 angstroms
everywhere, that
little 1 out of 5,000
controllability has been trans--
or variability,
which is not bad.
That'd be great if I got
whatever that percentage is--
0.02% or whatever.
That's amazing.
But it would magnify by
the time I etch down,
even if I could
etch uniformally.
There's just no way,
most importantly,
to be able to know when
you're within 100 angstroms
and be able to stop
controllably at that level.
So what do you think
they really do?
AUDIENCE: Etch all
the way through,
then grow another layer--
DUANE BONING: That's
exactly right.
We can controllably
etch all the way
through using ideas
of etch selectivity.
The same idea I mentioned of--
we can form the--
or choose an etch
chemistry that allows
us to etch silicon dioxide
and not etch photoresist.
We can also use to etch silicon
dioxide but not etch silicon,
can have very good
selectivity so that one
can stop controllably on
the surface of the silicon.
Now everybody
knows exactly where
they are across every
place in the wafer.
One can even over-etch
a little bit.
You don't even have to try
to set up a timed etch.
If I was etching at
1,000 angstroms a minute
and I started with
5,000 angstroms,
I might etch for five minutes.
But to be sure that I've got
the same degree of uniformity
everywhere, I might add
for an extra 10 seconds.
That way, I'm sure that I'm
clearing everywhere across
the wafer, even if there's
spatial non-uniformity
in my etch, or today's
etching's slightly slower than
yesterday's.
Then I can go back in and, with
different process conditions--
lower temperatures,
more pure chemicals,
or slightly different--
primarily different
temperature, or even
using alternative process
technologies that involve very,
very short time oxidations--
rapid thermal oxidations--
I can now controllably grow
up 1,000 angstroms, or 100
angstroms, or whatever I need.
So that's the first mistake.
I remember that one.
I think there's
another one someplace.
OK.
So still taking
this at face value,
we had the
photolithographic sequence
imprinted onto the photoresist.
We used that then to
controllability change
the permanent structure,
the silicon dioxide.
And then we remove using
another chemical solvent,
or in many cases, another
plasma etch, a plasma ash
that removes the
temporary photoresist.
Then we go on.
We've done that sequence.
We've now deposited
or grown, and then
spatially differentiated
to be able to create
one level of the structure.
And now we're going to
repeat that kind of idea
multiple times, and then mix in
a few additional transformation
steps.
Next step here as
we're depositing a--
our polysilicon layer.
Again, this will be fairly
highly doped either subsequent
to the deposition or
during the deposition.
It is a semiconducting layer,
but if one dops it-- that is,
adds elemental impurities of
a particular type to play with
the band structure
of the silicon--
one can make that behave in
a fairly metallic fashion.
And in the MOS transistor,
that polysilicon
is very highly doped, and is a
conductor under all conditions.
So we've deposited that.
What geometry do we want?
We want this thin
gate electrode,
so we're going to
do a photoresist--
or photolithographic
step again to do that--
deposit photoresist, expose.
In this case, here, again,
another positive photoresist
case-- so we're
blocking this structure.
We develop and dissolve away
the exposed photoresist,
and then we're doing a
plasma etch again to--
plasma etch to form
the gate electrode,
and then remove or ash
away the photoresist.
Now, this structure right
here is very, very critical.
This is the gate electrode.
Again, the current
is going to flow
in this direction along this
length underneath that gate
electrode in the silicon.
And this is referred to
as the channel length.
So the channel is the
structure that we're
going to create
underneath the silicon.
And the length of that
physical electrode
is very, very, very
critical in determining
many of the most
important characteristics
of the transistor.
You can think of it as--
and we're actually getting
closer in the dimensions
that we're talking about now--
that the time of
flight of an electron
underneath that
electrode will depend
on the width or the length
that it needs to transit.
We're getting close
to these velocity
limited transport regimes.
And so from one point
of view, the ability
or the speed of
the transistor is
critically dependent on
variations in that channel
length.
This is often referred
to as the CD of--
or one of the CDs of the
process, critical dimensions
of the process.
And in modern
technology, in fact,
that is perhaps the
smallest lateral dimension
that is determinative of the
generation of the technology
and the performance
and characteristics
of the technology.
So if we talk about a
65-nanometer technology,
they're talking typically
about that channel length,
that minimum feature
size being 65 nanometers.
In fact, often, tricks
are played where,
photolithographically, using the
exposure, that's the dimension
that they can form.
But you might actually
over-etch and shrink that,
get that to even a smaller
dimension than you could
photolithographically define
in order to boost the speed
and the controllability
of the device.
So this is very critical
lithography step and sequence.
Going on, the next
thing we need to do
is start to form the
source and drain regions.
We need to differentiate
the silicon underneath.
And what we're going to do here
is use another process, an ion
implantation process,
I believe, in this--
yes, I think that's what their
little picture there is--
where we actually implant
those [INAUDIBLE] atoms.
We shoot them with essentially
a high-energy electron or ion
gun into the silicon in a
very controlled fashion.
The guys who are
going to Varian here
in Gloucester, Massachusetts--
Varian sells ion implanters.
That's their business.
They're-- I don't know--
75% or something
of the market now.
They're dominant, and
they sell the equipment
for ion implantation.
There's also other competing
ion implant companies,
but most of them are
also in Massachusetts.
So Massachusetts is the ion
implant capital of the world.
The basic idea there,
again, is we're
highly doping in a controllable
fashion just these regions.
Those regions we don't want to
dope underneath the channel--
we want to keep
that fairly lightly
doped so that we can invert
it for electrical action.
And in this case, we're getting
something often referred
to as a self-aligned
process, whereby
we don't have to selectively
shoot the ions just in here.
We can blanket the whole wafer,
and use these thick oxide
and use the polysilicon
as the mask itself
to prevent the ions from
reaching the underlying silicon
regions.
So instead of having to put
down another photoresist layer
and try to open up just
exactly those regions,
and worry about aligning
of the physical mask
to match up exactly
with the existing
structures on the
wafer, we can take
advantage of the
underlying structures
to achieve that
spatial alignment.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you
elaborate a little bit
on the process of
placing this photoresist?
Seems like you're going to have
one [INAUDIBLE] put another.
How do you make sure
everything lines up the way
you need it to?
DUANE BONING: This is a
wonderful manufacturing control
challenge.
Overlay and alignment are--
almost more so than the physical
dimension that can be imaged
are the manufacturing
control problems.
There's more description
in May and Spanos.
But essentially, over time,
the ability to optically
line up the existing
structures--
typically, you might
actually use alignment marks
that you build up in
parallel to these transistors
to aid in the optical--
automatic optical recognition of
spatial locations on the wafer.
It's a huge challenge
to then line that up
with the physical mask plate,
such that you minimize offsets.
There's also exquisite
environmental control
in the equipment
that's used for this.
Imagine that I don't
need to line up just
for one transistor--
I got to make sure across maybe
a 1 centimeter squared or 2
centimeter squared chip
that all of my transistors
are lining up.
And in fact, in
older technologies,
I had to make sure the
whole wafer was lined up,
because I had a big glass plate
that I was using in almost
a one-for-one transformation, so
everything across a whole wafer
had to be lined up.
And if the temperature
of the glass plate
and out of the wafer
were off by a degree,
the thermal expansion
would upset the alignment,
for example.
So over time, you've seen--
both to achieve
smaller dimension,
but also to achieve
better control--
a number of [INAUDIBLE]
driver for the evolution
of the photolithographic
equipment.
One step was photolithographic
reduction from, say, a 10 to 1
or a 5 to 1 glass plate down
to a smaller chip or smaller
wafer.
The second was
chip-to-chip stepping.
So in fact, the
photolithography equipment's
typically called now a
stepper, because it's imaging
one field, maybe one chip.
There may be more than
one chip in each field,
but I'm stepping through
in order to get the control
and be able to achieve
the alignment on one
chip at a time.
And in the most
modern equipment,
in fact, they don't even image
the whole chip at one time.
They're imaging
slices of that so
that they can do all kinds
of other on the fly alignment
control, as well as
leveling, because turns out
the depth of focus
is a big constraint.
And if I have a
focal plane mismatch,
where I'm in focus on
the left side of the chip
and not on the right,
then I don't get
the dimensional control I need.
So it's really
amazing innovations
that are exactly driven
by the manufacturing
control necessary.
So there's a little
bit more description
in here talking about some
of that equipment as well.
In fact, I'm not really
talking here much
about the processing equipment.
I'm trying to get us
through at least the process
sequence, but the equipment
itself is fascinating.
It's really fascinating.
OK, we're almost there with
this device, because now we're
primarily just repeating these
same kinds of structures.
What we're going to do now is
another photolithography step.
Here, essentially what we want
to do with this yellow layer
is build up an insulating layer.
So I think a new layer of
silicon dioxide is deposited.
In this case, it's
not thermally grown
through that chemical
reaction of oxide.
And silicon-- because I've
already got polysilicon,
I've got--
well, I guess it actually
might work in this case.
I've already got a very thick
layer of silicon in this case,
we use typically a chemical
vapor deposition process--
again, in vacuum equipment.
But we decompose
silicon dioxide carrying
molecules in a gas plasma.
So there will be a more complex
molecule typically coming in,
and we decompose that,
and basically, it
snows on the
surface of the wafer
and builds up a
silicon dioxide layer.
So we deposit that
silicon dioxide,
and what we're going to do is
now open up holes within that
using a photolithography step.
You can see here's the mask,
where we want to open up
a hole; down, where we'll
be able to make contact
to the gate and make contact
to the source and drain.
So we go through again--
photolithography,
put our resist down, expose
it, develop it, plasma etch--
again, controllably
etching through the oxide,
stopping on the silicon layer.
Remove the photoresist, and
now we put down a metal layer.
Now, typically, what's
done for metal layers
is some form of physical
vapor deposition, where--
one example is a
metal evaporator
where the wafer will be
positioned some distance away
from a metal source.
The metal source-- aluminum
or other materials--
will be heated up, either
directly electrically
or under sputtering
kinds of activity,
such that either
individual molecules
or small agglomerations of
molecules become very excited,
and traject through the
vacuum, and build up the layer
on the surface of the wafer.
So in this case, this
is an older technology.
They're talking about
this being aluminum.
I'll show you a little
bit later that most
of the most advanced
chips are now
using a copper interconnect,
which has other challenges.
So the basic idea
is now, again, we've
covered the whole
surface of the wafer,
and we selectively go in
with a photolithography step
and remove where we don't want
the metal lines protected,
where I'm not going
to want to etch.
I'm protecting parts
of the aluminum,
and then I do a plasma
etch or a chemical
etch in order to
remove the aluminum.
And then I remove--
strip away the photoresist,
leaving my structure.
Now, this is a single level
metal, very simple transistor.
And building up a several
billion transistor
chip, or even a 100
transistor chip,
we now need to also
electrically interconnect
all of those devices.
And there's a whole additional
sequence of process steps
that are used to build multiple
levels of metal contact,
but conceptually, they're
very similar to those
that we've seen so far.
Here I've got access to
this individual transistor.
Clearly, laterally, I can
have neighboring transistors
that I've wired together
with the patterned aluminum.
When you get a certain
number of transistors,
it becomes very hard to have
just one level of wiring.
You need to be able
to have a wire that
goes over another
wire, and that's
where we get to multiple
level interconnect structures,
where one would deposit
another layer of silicon
dioxide or other insulator and
then build vertical [INAUDIBLE]
down from one level to the next
to contact multiple streets
on level 2 with streets on
level 1, and so on, up to 6,
8, or even 10 levels of
metal in modern structures.
AUDIENCE: So
[INAUDIBLE] are there
several transistors above
each other or just connectors?
DUANE BONING: Yeah--
good question.
Almost all existing
semiconductor chips
are planar processes, meaning
all of the transistors
are in just one plane, just
at the surface of the silicon.
In fact, let me
hand this around.
This just has a
copper interconnect
test pattern on it, so--
but this is an 8-inch
wafer, and the basic idea
is we can get that
very nicely grown
silicon layer and control of the
surface of the silicon layer.
It's actually quite
difficult to build up
multiple levels of independent
and high-quality silicon
layers on the wafer.
There's an awful
lot of research--
pass that around-- for
3D integrated circuits,
where one would, in fact, build
multiple strata or multiple
layers of transistors, and
then bond the wafers together
to be able to have in a
very compact form factor
multiple devices in
the third dimension.
You get lots of benefits
of smaller footprint.
At that coarse
level of 3D, I would
say many several memory chip
makers are already doing chip
stacking within one packet.
So in some of the memory chips,
if you were to etch away that--
the black packaging casing
around one of those chips,
you might find a stacking.
But they are not heavily
electrically interconnected.
It's not a fully
integrated structure.
In fact, at the end of
the day, they typically
have bond wires--
big macroscopic wires coming
in the sides of the chip
separately at each
of the stacking.
Now, there's other variants.
So for example, many of
the thin film transistor,
TFT displays will
actually have a layer
of transistors that are a
deposited layer of polysilicon,
not quite the same
pure crystalline layer.
And sometimes those include
stacked transistors.
So there are some technologies.
They're just not
quite the same quality
or the same high-speed nature.
OK, anybody detect any other
obvious mistakes or errors
in their pictures?
Maybe it was just that
one, that one inability
to control of the etch
down to a 100 angstroms.
Now, there's lots of other
abstractions in here.
And one of the other neat
things in this picture is it's
showing--
you're building up a
fairly complicated geometry
using controllable processes.
One of the most
important things that you
have for control of this
lateral differentiation
is photolithography.
Notice, we were never
just depositing directly
aluminum where we wanted it.
It's always a--
deposit everywhere,
because you can do that across--
in parallel across the
whole surface of the wafer,
and then have to go back
and do a subtractive process
to typically remove
what you want.
There are very, very few steps
where you can selectively
grow or selectively add
material only where you want it.
So that's an example
of a huge constraint
in semiconductor processing.
So what I want to
do now, with that
as the overview of
the unit process
and how they all
stack up to build
a more complicated structure--
I want to talk a
little bit about of
the input-output picture of
semiconductor processing.
This is very similar to
our generic picture that--
hopefully you guys have started
reading that process control
overview--
where we've got different
inputs to the unit process,
including the raw
material, the wafer.
We've got inputs in
terms of the environment
that we create
around the wafer--
that vacuum process, the
chemical [INAUDIBLE],,
the gas ambient used in
plasma etching; and then
other control factors
on the machine
or the facility-- things
like thermal control
in photolithography--
to be able to ensure
that there's not thermal
expansion of the components.
And then we get changes in
many of these wafers, many
of these states.
Many of these are desirable.
We saw the change in the wafer
state in terms of the geometry,
as well as things
like doping processes
that change the conductivity
of the silicon layers.
But we also often
have the side effects
changes in the state
of the equipment.
And this turns out to
be a big deal in much
of semiconductor control.
So for example, every one
of those coating processes
occurs in some
kind of a chamber.
I coat up a film.
I coat aluminum on the
surface of the wafer.
What do you think happens
to the rest of the chamber?
It gets coated too.
So over time, you will often
get buildup of material
in the rest of the
equipment, and there
will need to be other steps
to go in and clean or reset
the equipment state.
So actually, we
often are worried
not only about the
product and what's
happening with the product,
but in manufacturing control,
we're also very
worried about what's
happening with the equipment.
So what we often don't
have control over
are all these disturbances.
There may be variations
in the process coming
from lots of different sources.
Some might be the
incoming material.
In this case, if
there's variability
in the starting wafer, or
the wafer as processed up
to some step, that might
interact with the step
that we're now performing, and
limit our ability to control.
And then similarly,
there may be influences
of variation coming from the
machine, or the facility,
or the wafer environment.
So what I want to do
is talk a little bit
about some of those different
kinds of variations,
and build on what
we've seen here.
Now, I mentioned this
a little bit last time.
It used to be 10 years
ago, 15 years ago,
if we talked about yield--
the percentage of
functioning devices
that came out of
semiconductor fab--
the main worry limiting
yield was particle defects.
And you can imagine, we're
talking about very, very
small features here.
And if pieces of extraneous
matter were to fall between,
say, two metal lines that would
cause an electrical short--
or could cause an
electrical short--
and now the device
does not function.
It does not function correctly.
In other cases, the
particle-- if it happened
to appear in the photoresist,
it might cause an open
in one of these lines.
It might prevent-- or cause
me to actually regions
where I didn't want to.
So not only can I have shorts--
I might have opens
between lines.
And this defect control
was the primary source
of yield loss in the fab.
That's why, if you go into
an IC fab, it's a clean room.
Everybody's wearing
clean room garments.
There's incredible
amounts of airflow
to filter out and
remove all kinds of dust
particles or other
extraneous matter
down to very, very
tiny dimensions.
That's really the
measures that have
been taken in order
to get the cleanliness
you need in order to--
not eliminate, but get
those particles down
to a particle density and
down to a presence of size
that are small enough not to
have too big of a yield impact.
What I mean by size is imagine
that little dust particle
is only a quarter of the width
of any of the minimum feature
sizes on your structure.
Well, that might mean I lose
a quarter of the width of one
of those metal lines, but
at least it still conducts.
It might have a slightly higher
resistance than I expect,
but functionally, I'm still OK.
Similarly, if it's too
small of a particle
to bridge between lines, I'm
not going to have a short.
So the idea is to control
the particles down
to a certain feature.
Now, there are some very
interesting manufacturing
control technologies
that are used
to characterize the
presence and density
of these kinds of particles.
And what I pictured
here is a metal layout,
a metal patterned structure--
referred to as a nest
structure--
that allows one to build a large
number of these snaking lines,
and electrically connect
between these different lines
in order to test if there is a
bridging defect between lines,
and count the number
of those events.
So you build this structure
to spatially sample
as large an area as you
can to try to capture
some number of these defects.
And you can also
use this structure
to characterize the
size of these defects,
especially if they're
relatively large.
So for example, if I
had a big particle that
bridged three of these lines,
I know, within certain bounds,
that I've got a particle
between some size interval.
And so that's what's
shown over here
is a defect count as a
function of the size,
in microns, of different
particles for these large area
sampling structures.
Now, this turns
out to be still a--
an important part of
semiconductor fabrication
is understanding your
defect densities,
defect counts, understanding
what the typical sizes are,
what levels of the
process they come in.
Are you mostly getting these
in aluminum deposition?
in other etch processes?
And actually, then
feeding that information
to design for
manufacturability to optimize
the layout of the
circuit to minimize
the likelihood of a particle
falling in a bad location.
And we'll talk about
that, I think, somewhere
near the midpoint or second--
last third of the course.
We'll talk about yield modeling
and some of the technologies
that are used for
characterizing, statistically,
the point defects,
particle defects, and some
of the strategies used for
optimizing or minimizing impact
on circuits.
But what is becoming
much more important--
and we mentioned this
on Tuesday as well--
is parametric control.
And in some cases,
even these defect
controls turn into
parametric control problems
if what I'm worried about is not
so much yes-no functionality,
but changes in the
resistance of lines because
of the presence of defects.
And so much more
broadly than defects,
we're much more concerned
with continuous parameter
control of geometry as well as
some of these other properties
that we saw in the sequence.
So for example, that
critical dimension control
might be the channel length
of transistors on my device,
and inherently,
you're going to have
some statistical distribution
on channel length.
Call that L.
So for example, if I were--
let me start down here--
if I were to sample many
nominally identical transistors
that were laid out
exactly the same,
were assumed to behave
and I measured some
electrical characteristic
or some geometric
characteristic,
I might get a distribution--
drawn here as a Gaussian.
It's not always, but very
often, that's a great model
and I might have
some distribution
of that across the chip.
And very often, there are
inherent physical limitations
in the process that give rise
to those sources of variation,
some of which we'll come
back to-- might be systematic
or might be random.
Now, what's interesting is
we have a physical nesting.
On the wafer, we
have many chips.
Now, if I were to
take and measure
the same transistor
on each chip,
I would also get a distribution.
I have a chip-to-chip
variability in parameters,
and often that will come because
of different physical causes.
It may be we're doing that
photolithographic stepping,
and every time, I have a little
bit different overlay control
or offset control.
So the source of this may be--
this distribution may be
because of wafer level
or across wafer sources
of variation that
are very different than the
sources of physical variation
of replication of
transistors within the chip.
And we also can have
wafer-to-wafer variations.
Again, if I were to either
calculate the average over one
wafer, or maybe
just sample exactly
the same location on every
wafer and stack that up
across 24 wafers or large
numbers of wafers that
might be in one lot, processed
even relatively close in time
to each other, there's also
going to be a deviation.
And that might arise because of
changes in the equipment state
from one run to the next.
The first wafer-- it may
have a pristine equipment
with no build-up on the-- of
material on the wafer wall.
The next wafer might see a
slightly different process--
unintentionally-- than the
previous one because of changes
or degradation in the
equipment state over time
affecting that wafer state.
That might be an example.
And then finally, in
semiconductor fab,
we typically are
processing a lot of wafers.
That may be 24 wafers at a time.
And from one lot
to the next, these
might be processed at
substantially different points
in time.
And there may be another
distribution associated
with that, and
physical sources are
causes of that
variation that are
different than these other
spatial or temporal sources.
Some companies-- and
there's not a lot of them
these days-- have multiple fabs,
so I could continue this up.
Intel in particular is
very famous for making
the same product in multiple
fabs, in multiple states,
and in fact, multiple
countries around the world.
And they work very, very hard
to have matching from one fab
to the other, in
terms of the equipment
and so on, to minimize
fab-to-fab deviations
or differences in their chips.
They really don't
want people saying,
I'm only going to buy
my Pentium or Itanium
chip from the Albuquerque
fab, because it's
better than the one from
Portland or whatever.
They really want
to minimize that.
So you've got extensions
up the hierarchy as well.
Now, if we were to
actually zoom in
on one of those
distributions, what's also
going to be very
interesting is trying
to understand what the
sources of variation
are at each of the
spatial scales.
And you might have a fairly
complex distribution, say,
over channel length.
And what's often very, very much
the case, and very interesting
is that total distribution
is the compounded effective
multiple additional sources
that are convolved together.
And a lot of work will be done
in designing test procedures,
designing process
control charts,
and whatnot to be able to
track individual contributors
and separate them out into the
component sources of variation.
Why do you want to do this?
If you can identify
individual sources,
that's crucial to being able
to go and squeeze them down.
You got to know what the source
is in order to remove it.
What else is the case
often is that some of these
are not completely random.
Many of the sources
of variation have
a systematic physical cause.
And if we understand what
is systematic or repeatable
every time you run
this, you might actually
find that the transistor in the
upper right corner of the chip
is a little bit too wide.
You might then
track that back to
the photolithographic
imperfection that's
causing that.
Once you know that, you can
compensate and counteract
that source of variation.
A lot of the work is
trying to break these down.
So let me give you a little
bit more example of some
of these sources of variation,
and the tools and techniques
that are evolving
to handle them.
Let me zoom into
one unit process.
We've done actually
a lot of research
on chemical mechanical
polishing in semiconductor fab.
And the basic process is you
take that wafer, you press it--
or you hold it in
a wafer carrier
and press it face down
onto a rotating table
or [INAUDIBLE] to which is
affixed an abrasive path.
You also drip a wet
abrasive slurry--
so it's a very, very
fine particle grit--
in a chemically active
slurry, and then
you rotate both the wafer
and the pad, or the table.
And the basic goal
of this is to flatten
the surface of the wafer, if
you go back to this picture,
with even one level of metal,
look at all of the topography,
the differences in heights
that are generated,
because we're etching down,
filling in, and so on.
If one were to try to build
multiple levels of metal,
you have a real problem here.
You keep building up
in some regions where
you have more metal,
and in those regions
where you don't, you get thinner
and thinner by comparison.
That becomes a huge challenge
in terms of other processes,
like photolithography-- talked
about that depth of focus.
Now I want a pattern or image at
the top of one of these levels,
and I've got also these
recessed regions--
become very difficult to
image, say, a metal 4 layer.
And so CMP has been
created to basically
abrade away the raised
surfaces, get it
down to a planar surface.
Now, one of the
big problems in CMP
is the process itself is
often not all that stable.
That polishing pad,
that abrasive path--
what happens if
you use sandpaper
for a while on a piece of wood?
Well, you smooth out
the grain or whatever
in the piece of wood.
What happens to your sandpaper?
It also wears-- fills in.
It gets gooky.
Basically, it
changes its state--
the process and the
equipment changes
it state over
fabrication as well.
And if you looked at the
normalized removal rate
for a 350-wafer
sequence, you will often
find drift in the removal rate.
You might start out with a
fairly high removal rate,
and over time, it drifts down.
This is something like at
20% or 40% kind of drift.
Similarly, if you
looked at the wafer--
measured some pattern,
some eight-sample point,
and calculated a
non-uniformity metric--
maybe its standard
deviation of those points--
one would find--
maybe you can see
it-- looks like there's a slight
increase in that non-uniformity
over time.
The pad is not quite
as uniform as well.
So this is the kind of temporal
wafer-to-wafer variation
that you don't want, and
would like to understand it.
If there's a systematic
trend, then maybe there
are control approaches that
can be used to compensate
or correct for that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This polishing
seems to be a bad idea to me.
[INAUDIBLE] a way to getting,
like you said, [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah.
The semiconductor industry
really got its start
about 1960, and for
30 years, it was all
about defects, those particles.
Keep them away from the
wafer at whatever cost.
And then primarily, folks
from IBM around 1990
said, yeah, we're
going to pour slurries
with 100-nanometer
particles on it,
and then we're going
to rub the heck out
of the surface of your wafer.
And everybody thought
they were crazy.
But it turns out that, first
off, the control of the process
can be very good in
terms of not a very, very
fine abrading of the surface.
So you're not gouging out.
You're really doing almost
nanometer-by-nanometer scale
abrasion.
But then you still have
all those particles.
So a lot of the work was very,
very effective post-polish
cleaning processes that
involve chemical baths,
that involve brush
cleaning, in fact,
that involve hydroponic
agitation to levitate
the particles off of the surface
of the wafer in a clean bath--
that they actually found no
appreciable defect-oriented
yield loss, once you did
those extreme measures
to clean up the wafer.
And in fact, the
irony ended up being
that the CMP processed,
by planarizing, actually
improved the defectivity.
Because many of these particles
might be present in layer 3,
you've got a lump, but it didn't
destroy the action of level 3.
But if it's sticking up, by
the time you go in to level 4
and you do a
metalization over that,
well, now you've got a problem.
And the CMP process, which would
go in and flatten or planarize
between levels, would
actually chop the heads off
of these defects and
reduce their impact
for subsequent levels.
But it is a fascinating
story of the adoption of CMP,
because it was so
counterintuitive of a process,
exactly as you said.
So we'll come back at the end
or later to control strategies,
for dealing with this--
of the course.
Basically, this
kind of a drift--
you could start to think,
well, I can measure this,
and maybe what I would like
to do on subsequent runs--
if my removal rate
has drifted down,
I'd like a strategy
where I polish
a little bit longer or I
press a little bit harder--
these sorts of things.
AUDIENCE: So you only do this
polishing at the very end?
DUANE BONING: No.
You do it at each level--
AUDIENCE: At each level
DUANE BONING: --each
metal level, as well as
in some other places.
So it's actually used repeatedly
in multilevel interconnect.
Here's an example of
a little test chip
to try to characterize some
of those spatial variations,
and decompose them
that we talked about.
This is a chip design that has
a few thousand ring oscillators.
A ring oscillator is a chain
of an odd number of inverters,
each of which does a
logic zero to one or one
to zero computation.
And if you organize
those in a ring fashion,
it oscillates at
some high frequency
that indicates the speed of
the individual transistors
in that structure.
So a ring oscillator is a
wonderful stand-in electronic
circuit telling you a lot about
the speed of your technology.
What we did is built
a tiled architecture,
where we've got thousands of
these structures; replicated
spatially, so now we can
measure multiple instances
and see if there's
a spatial pattern;
well as we can
also play with some
of the design parameters of
each of those ring oscillators.
And in particular,
we can do things
like take that
silicon gate electrode
and split it into three of them.
We can play with the spacing
between those electrodes.
We can orient those
[INAUDIBLE] vertically
or horizontally on the layout.
We can also look at the
effective nearby structures.
For example, how
dense per unit area
do you have transistors or
polysilicon gate electrodes?
Would that have an effect
on the ring oscillator?
And now, if you go
out and build this,
this is a wonderful
kind of data,
where you can
aggregate or map out
the data at these
different spatial scales
to look for trends.
So for example, if we look
at the wafer scale variation
in the ring oscillator
speed, we've
got something like 30 chips
in the upper half of one
of these wafers.
And mapped out
here and the color
is the average ring oscillator
speed from high to low.
And you can see a spatial trend
from one side of the wafer
to the other.
This is telling us there is
a wafer level non-uniformity,
and in fact, that across
wafer variation is about 9%
in speed of these devices.
You can also then
start to look--
I guess that's the same thing--
you can also start
to look and say,
depending on how you
designed the transistor,
what kind of offsets do
you get in the frequency
and what kind of
variation do you
get in the speed of the devices?
And what's interesting here
is that many of these ring
oscillator designs are--
from the circuit designer
perspective, they think
of them as identical.
But in fabrication,
because of neighborhood
or nearby structures, in fact,
there are slight deviations.
So nominally
identical transistors
may, in fact, have substantial
systematic, highly repeatable
effects.
And if the manufacturing line
can capture and characterize
those, and send that
information to design,
design can compensate.
So this is another theme.
This design and manufacturing
link can be very important.
We can also map out
identical transistors
within one of these chips.
And here again, you can see
a top-to-bottom variation
in the ring oscillator speed.
And in this case, that
within each individual chip
is about 4% in this
particular case,
which is quite interesting.
Notice we said there's 9%
across the whole wafer.
I might have 10 chips lined
up in a line across the wafer.
If I were to say,
from center to edge,
I have a systematic trend--
or from one edge of
the way for the other,
the systematic trend
of about 10%, and I
map that down to
1/10, because I've
got 10 ships, that would
be about a 1% variation,
you might expect, because
of wafer level sources
on each chip.
But what we find is something
like 4% That's telling us
there's a different source
of physical variation at work
within each of the chips.
And then you can also look
for other systematic effects--
things like the proximity of
one [INAUDIBLE] to another
can have
photolithographic effects.
And in particular, that
can result in an offset,
depending on whether I
have 1 micron, or 2 micron,
or 2x, or 3x spacing
between the devices.
But in this case, the variation
across many, many replicates
of each of those
is about the same.
An interesting
effect is, if we take
that same [INAUDIBLE] that
single gate electrode and split
it up into two, or
split it up into three,
and then look at the effect
on ring oscillator speed
offset and variance, what do
you think we're going to see?
We didn't know, so
you may not know.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Probably
see four variations
in the [INAUDIBLE] one
because there are more edges.
DUANE BONING: Right,
you have more edges.
And that's exactly.
If we look at the sigma with
one finger, two finger, or four
finger, we found a proportional
increase in the variance,
with more opportunities for
variation by the fingering.
So that was an interesting
implication for some design
kinds of effects.
OK, so that's an example
where design of experiments
could be used to come
up with test structures,
and characterize,
and split out some
of these sources of variation.
Now, I'm not going to
go into the full detail
on these slides.
I put more slides in
here than I needed
because this is a current
area of my research
and I get really
excited about it.
But it helps
explain a little bit
this multilevel interconnect.
I'll cover the first
one very briefly.
There's two sequences
that I didn't
talked about in the
earlier flow, because it's
a 10-year-old process.
Modern integrated
circuits-- especially
for microprocessor logic,
and now even memory--
are using copper interconnect.
Copper conducts
better than aluminum.
You get speed improvements.
You get reliability
improvements.
It's a big drive
to move to copper.
But it's a little bit more
complicated of a process.
The basic process is
different than an aluminum,
because we do not have
an effective plasma etch
process for the removal--
selective removal of copper.
It's just a bad
process in that way.
So instead, what we have to
do is go through the following
sequence.
We go to photolithographically
etch in our insulating layer
where we want, ultimately,
the copper line to reside.
Then we fill in
copper everywhere.
We happen to do that using
an electroplating process,
and that electroplating
process results
in nice filling of features
of different sizes,
but it also overfills.
And even more problematic is it
overfills to different amounts
or different thicknesses
depending on the feature size
that we filled up.
So you get this very
complicated topography.
Now, I described CMP as
wonderful for flattening
and removing and
abrading away topography.
So the second step is
using CMP to remove
all this excess copper.
And it will polish away.
And ideally, you would
like to stop exactly
on the surface of the oxide and
have your nice remaining copper
lines where you wanted them.
But it also has a geometric
imperfection arising from
over-polish, where
big fat wide lines--
the polishing pad-- that
polyurethane pad-- actually
digs down in and over-polishes
certain features.
And in regions where
you've got a lot of copper
and very little hard
supporting oxide,
it actually erodes
down in appreciably.
So these are some
systematic effects.
They are manufacturing
limitations,
and one would like to model
and characterize those.
And in fact, that's what
this waiver was for.
What we came up with was a test
structure methodology where
you would put lots of features
of different sizes on a wafer,
run it through the process,
measure the results--
so this is a measurement of
the electroplated profile
for different feature sizes,
like those little lines
and spaces between the lines of
quarter micron, quarter micron,
versus say 100 micron
and 100 micron lines.
And then you could measure
the surface topography
and see how much overinflating
or how much underfill you might
have in each of those regions.
Now, this is kind of a
neat example for something
that we'll be learning about
later in the term, which
is empirical modeling.
This is an empirical process,
where we run the wafer through,
we take measurements,
and then we developed
in our first-level
model response
surface models
that are basically
power models as a function
of line width and line space.
So you can empirically
fit a model
that describes how
much overplating height
or what the step
height might be.
And then one can use that
to characterize step height
or the amount of bulge as a
function of line width and line
space, and give some
feedback to the designers
saying, hey, if you
design in these ranges.
This is what's actually
going to happen,
as opposed to what you
thought was going to happen.
And so that's a little
response-- surface model
kind of example.
And then one can also
build those perhaps
into design tools that could
predict for a whole chip--
maybe a product chip--
what the electroplated
process thickness would be
or what the CMP
process would be.
I'm going to skip these.
This is essentially doing
the same thing for CMP,
but the idea here is this
linkage, again, between design
and manufacture, where
the manufacturing fab can
characterize what the actual
amount of dishing or erosion
is going to be for very
complicated product chips.
And that information could
get fed back to the designer
so that they actually
know, in this location,
my final copper wire is going to
be this thick, not this thick.
And that could be
very important,
because the thickness
of a copper wire
determines its
electrical resistance.
It even affects the
coupling capacitance
between to neighbor wires.
So those key
electrical parameters--
resistance, capacitance-- that
determine interconnect speed
depend on that critically.
So that linkage with robust
design can be very important.
One can also use
those kinds of models
to play with process
parameters, and empirically,
as a function of the
process conditions,
minimize these systematic
sources of variation.
And one approach that
is dominant in a number
of industries is a capturing
of these dependencies on design
features, like line
width or line space,
and what is a good
region to be operating
in in these ideas
of design rules.
And so in fact,
this is some work
from LSI Logic looking at
the copper interconnect space
and saying, OK, what
region, what limits,
what combinations of line width
and line space can you have,
and where are the
boundaries because
of some of these different
physical effects?
So for example,
photolithography says
I can't patent smaller
than certain dimensions.
Dishing limits, that dishing
down into wide features,
says I can't have features
wider than 10 microns.
I'll dish them too much.
So this is another
way of coupling
between design and manufacture.
And then the last
thing I've already
alluded to, but coming
back to the CMP problem,
we also can develop--
and we'll talk about response
surface or empirical models
that say, OK, here's
what the removal rate is,
or the non-uniformity is as a
function of some of the process
conditions, like the
speed of rotation,
or the pressure or
downforce of rotation.
And once you have a
basic control model--
for example, the
normalized removal rate
is a function of
downforce and speed--
I've got some input-output
empirical relationship between
these--
I can now use this in a
run-by-run control kind
of feedback situation, where
I make a measurement on every
wafer that comes out--
what the average
removal rate was--
use that together with
this empirical model,
perhaps do a model update
to track the changing state
of the equipment and pad as--
it also gets perturb from run
to run--
use that do model to
say, for the next wafer,
change the recipe slightly.
Polish a little bit longer
or press a little bit
harder to compensate
for that known
characterized variation source.
And so this is just an example.
You can imagine that, using
these simplified models,
one can have some
compensation strategy that
brings the removal
rate back up to target.
And so we'll talk about that
in the latter part of the term
as well.
These are just examples
showing, for different numbers
of wafers, you have
to actually change
the speed or the
pressure, downforce,
but you can get very good
control of the output.
So to wrap up for today,
this was a whirlwind tour
through the semiconductor
fabrication process,
and I hope you have a feel
for the myriad different kinds
of variations that are out
there, and a glimpse forward
to some of the
techniques that we're
going to be developing through
the term to deal with this.
So we'll see you on Tuesday.
Dave will be giving
that lecture and talking
about the rest of the
processes out there
in the world besides
semiconductor fabrication,
and building up some
intuition that we'll
use in those processes.
So get started on the
problem set as well.